Chris is rocking some cool kids is
interesting that I do have cool shoes
hey everybody welcome to the other show
I'm Sarah I'm Chris and we're here
talking about the finale of the other
two with case Hellena and drew he is
wearing a literal bird cage full of bird
but not real birds it's actually really
fun to come to work and see what you
were gonna be wearing every episodes you
had some amazing wardrobe it was cool a
couple days before we did all the
costumes they had a brand they bring all
the costumes in my house and I tried
them all on and I'm like okay yeah Jill
bream did the costumes and is incredible
and does costumes at SNL too and then
sometimes she would sew it show us
something and we were like I don't know
what and then she's like trust me when
it's on him it will be correct and it
always was my favorite was the Versace
like yeah it's like oh and like the
crazy jacket on the plane at the club
yeah the birdcage outfit was funny too I
didn't know what to expect they were
like you're gonna wear a birdcage I'm
like what
whoever does that VMA vo is like yeah
the woman who does yeah it's actual
right now you know so good it feels very
real yeah we did it with her and she did
like a couple and she's like any notes
I'm you're like no that's what it is
yeah
party till you read so dance until you
stay
this episode was chases big perform yeah
yeah we went to the studio with case and
recorded that song and then tweaked it
yup and then we tweaked a little bit I
know it was very weird to be like we
need you to sound bad but not comedy bad
believable bad yeah you feel bad it
can't be like your obvious you're
missing notes it has to be like natural
little yes we had record it and have you
kind of miss no time Ennis notes try
somewhere you'd sing a little well and
yeah we would mess it up yep
was that bizarre to do it was when I
went in there I didn't really know what
to expect but I was like okay I kind of
because I've seen people like in real
life you know mess up on award show and
it's like it's still it's still good but
it's like now that wasn't right it
wasn't in my opinion when I was in there
I was like oh it's not that hard to do
but it was in true it was we gonna do it
wasn't hard it was just weird yeah yeah
we wanted this to be just almost
imperceptibly that we're every tweet is
bad the Burger King account is like
ripping him apart my son is a good
singer okay he just doesn't have an ear
for music so what either of you guys
like biffed it's so hard life or
anything I have I did wicked on the road
and a couple of times like went up on my
lion in front of like barn house it
that's especially crazy cuz you've been
you've done that show a thousand times
and you're like how can I would have if
you've done it the show a thousand times
you start to like while you're doing it
your brain can go so many different
places cuz you've said those words so
many times that you're thinking about
something else and then you're like oh
my god I forgot about Hellena on earth
needs to remember what's coming out of
her face and then if you start to be
like I've done this so many times I
wonder what would happen if I forgot it
what would happen if I forgot it what
would happen if I forgot it and you're
like good I had like really acted since
college like every gay person but I
still have dreams to this day of like
going up on a line have you biffed it
hard yes yes all of my youtube videos
are bits
career news was ours
[Music]
try to figure out how to end this season
for a while and we were curious about
like how to keep the premise of the
other two you feeling like the others so
we came up with the idea that Molly
would be famous now that that Pat the
mom would you kind of slowly but surely
you see like oh it makes sense like she
has been taking advantage of all these
opportunities
I loved that teaser at the end I would
watch Pat especially like Molly Molly
should have a talk show Molly and I was
like why isn't this a real thing like
let's really glad you're all here
because I've been thinking and I have a
big announcement all this singing stuff
has been really cool but this fall I'm
gonna go to college what in this episode
you to become even more connected to
chase and you hold their future in your
hands and you don't know it yeah you
don't know that she's your manager and
that he's your co-star well I'm so
innocent I'm like what's going on Oh
like their whole lives are depending on
me what you think it's interesting
moving forward if he has said he doesn't
want to do this anymore and if the
family makes him or doesn't make him or
like you guys all need him in a way now
where that is tricky weird like that was
never your intention going into but I
don't know that kind of stuff
interesting tonight and then I don't
want to do this stuff but they're kind
of like no you have to yeah they just do
this one thing that you're the
breadwinner yeah the like you are the
reason that everyone has the things they
have accidentally that's one of the
reasons we had you be like Brooke and I
will always listen to you because it
does set up this premise that he's your
little brother and you guys will listen
to him and then immediately that's
tested no wonderful rise to the occasion
or be garbage people
[Music]
you